c'est ce que finir suffit de taper juste
dérapage afida turner sont google tv
publique elles sont directement faux
total et six fois août à défoncer les
gens de manière je vais déjà ta mère à
l'aube mais l'attenté jeudi excuse moi
mais le mal est finie
c'est
tout le monde je vous réponds je vous ai
écouté cette fois ci je veux pas comme
interrompre vous savez c'est pas parce
qu'on passe à la télé qu'on reçoit des
tweets qu'on se fait insulter du matin
au soir et maintenant laissez moi parler
moi le moment donné je suis une femme un
être humain et je me réveille au matin
auquel je parlais pas commun de lyon
quand on me dit sale arabe ça n'aiderait
pas au boulot je dis ça c'est un
clochard personnes de 10 août mais pas
mon avocat aux barreaux mais géra plus
les trucs mais non mais je ne vois pas
bien lui quand une idée truc je
m'intéresse à la main tu recommences
routière 92e short usé fatigué mais pas
deux
quand tu dis qu'on est passé 300 cas
c'est bon quand tu
dis
merde foutez-moi finale
y'en a pas
m
c'est moins tape à montsalvy ghost je
t'offre un micro ça tu dis quand tu dis
afida qu'on n'est pas
au mieux non et moi j'ai ça tu dis ça
sur le plateau en direct etc et le
producteur est l'animateur qui ne te
reprennent pas c'est objectivement faux
une famille tout en tanins termine et
c'est pourquoi je faisais
tout et je dis dieu je suis gêné par
cela c'est
une honte ils se battent en retraite
parce que j'en ai marre mais toi tu n'as
donc c'est impossible par la route et
vous avez votre temps diminué dans quel
autre avec lui c'est quand je n'ai pas
le cas c'est la roma qui jeta prix de
moto contre tu fais et cadets ampleur et
la semaine mais non ils continuent et
continuent à dénigrer non mais je n'y
crois pas mais n'est-ce pas fini non je
me suis longtemps réalisation plus les
joues ya 270 places pas si c'est ça
aussi on tu ne peux plus rien y
critiquer alors ces plaintes ou les et
c'est encore déclaré soir c'est françois
valade est jaloux c'est pas gare d'agen
l'ouvragé mon port arrête tu peux pas
toi faire le trait vides mais monsieur
[Rires]
mais d'un côté prôner
pas dire à combien toi
laurent tu arrêtes maintenance et
analyserez vizir cas de son 100ème
place c'est pour maintenant quand tu dis
là je lui met une
chose dans l'humour qui fait que serrer
les dents le sait pas alors raymond remo
un [ __ ]
on va le bouquet une un théâtre comme ça
en mars qui veulent bouffer des
données qui est quand même gênant ça
[Rires]
[Musique]
ma mère
alors maman ce pas dans la même c'est
vraiment amer mais oui
si vous avez vu comment il a réussi
alors non mais il donc c'est pas dans la
même catégorie alors je suis désolé mais
vous êtes vous êtes moi je trouve que
quand on est méchant comme vous vous
êtes
j'admire a le côté jeu mais les couilles
sur la table ça je pourrais pas le faire
bien sûr
mais vous êtes trop premier degré ll
parfois je vous dis des choses méchantes
mais elle est dans le show elle est dans
l'humour tout pas tant mais non ils à
leurs ailerons mais gêné par ce show
vous savez quoi comme c'est bon
[Applaudissements]
au tribunal de grande instance de lure
noah faut le maximum
d'efforts ne peut en bus c'est une faute
c'est durant du coup je suis d'accord à
coiffer ses marges en qu'est ce qui t'a
amené ma mère
laberge des fins peu l'indéfendable mais
je sens qu'on est on peut se comprendre
avec afida comprendre non j'ai dû en
faire une robe bandage sur quelques
valises et des conseils sur les hommes
alors j'aimerais le savoir est ce que c
est ce que vous êtes plus drôle au
terrain de trévise que ce soir mais
mieux vaut en tout cas beaucoup plus
drôle
[Applaudissements]
vous pourrez constater dans mon billet
en question benjamin le blondinet ils
ont commis des attentats preuve un
coiffeur de vannes a
[Applaudissements]
pu naître en espace et en
colère parce que c'était effectivement
violent maladroit voilà tout le contexte
ça mais après moi je pense que vous
jouissez quand même de cette situation
oui c'est non aujourd'hui c'est non pas
ce soir
là bas tout et pour tout et c'est bon on
fera un livre plus tard sur la
jouissance
[Musique]
je souhaite à tous
bouts de coeur et beaucoup plus marque
beaucoup de gens mais
alors jean-claude mais en fait moi
je vais fermer puis moi que vous écoutez
pas
bien ce que fait gerald bit parce que
suite
très expressive
déjà dit quoi sur ton corps
[Musique]
s'écrira sans grille et
pousse la épouse la cua by
me de ben jonson j'adore ça à sa
façon je sens bon de suite de
plus important le signe de la lune
ravise requiem pour un con